oculus rift was a good VR headset when I
launched in March but it's tech was
overshadowed by the HTC vive released
hot on its heels
HTC's VR system offered one-to-one
motion track controllers and a more
immersive room scale experience August
touch is the company's attempt to bridge
the gap the controllers bring your hands
into VR with the same level of precision
as the vive controllers it's not cheap
at $1.99 but it is worth it the small
controllers can be a bit confusing to
hold at first since they look bizarre
and it's not immediately clear which
controller belongs to which hand they
are really light and 136 grams and they
do feel really comfortable and ergonomic
to hold the controllers have a lot of
buttons and they can seem a bit
overwhelming at first especially since
you're effectively blindfolded from them
in VR
fortunately oculus includes tutorials
that walk you through the controllers of
various capabilities oculus has also
implemented tools for touch that allow
you to lift your thumb off the
controller to give the thumbs-up gesture
similarly when you lift your index
finger off the trigger button your
virtual index finger will point setting
up touch is straightforward and there's
an on-screen tutorial that walks you
through the process
oculus recommends that you place it's
two sensors in front of you which will
provide you a play space that measures
up to two by two meters but there's also
an experimental 360-degree setup which
allows you to place one of the sensors
behind you to prevent the controllers
from being occluded or blocked from the
consolation tracking system however
there are two issues with this
configuration it shrinks your play space
down to 1.5 by 1.5 meters but the bigger
issue is that the sensors 8 foot cable
isn't long enough to go behind your back
without a USB extension cord there's
another experimental room-scale setup
that allows you to walk around a larger
2.5 by 2.5 meters space if you purchase
a third sensor which is sold separately
for $79 I tried it with the USB
extension cable and while it does
increase the playable boundary the
biggest thing holding room-scale back
here is the headsets a relatively short
cable at about 12.5 feet it's too short
to allow you to walk around very much
and currently feels like an afterthought
this isn't as big of an issue with the
vibe which has a cable that measures
over 16 feet I played a bunch of games
to put the controllers to the test I'm
glad to say that they performed a really
even with a traditional to front-facing
sensor setup the controllers rarely got
obscured controllers will generally only
lose tracking if I turn my back towards
the sensors and held them too close to
my body or position them beneath the
sensors tracking is also accurate once
you learn the layout of the controller
it feels really natural to pick up
objects fire guns wave at allies and
more it's so accurate than when I shoot
basketballs in VR Sports challenge I can
get a strong sense of whether shots will
land before they even hit the backboard
tagging artwork and King spray graffiti
simulator I could finally control the
intensity of my spray can with touches
analog trigger which offers a lot of
pressure granularity that such as haptic
engine is also fantastic playing the 1v1
wizard dueling game the unspoken I could
feel how powerful my charging fireballs
were by how violent the controllers
showed the touch controllers don't just
open up new gameplay opportunities from
the oculus store but on Steam as well in
its pre release date that touch
controllers work relatively well with
the motion track games designed for the
bottom there are even icons for the
touch controllers in steamvr s menu the
biggest issue at the moment is that the
buy controllers are rendered in VR and
luuv touch this can be a bit awkward and
disorienting at first oh take you a
minute or two to figure out how steamvr
has remapped the buttons the
controller's tracking system is still
great in Steam titles but I couldn't set
up Steam viewers chaperone system I
played through space pirate trainer
trials and tat tween and Valve's the lab
on steam everything worked bow at 199
oculus touch isn't cheap but it gets
your hands into VR and allows you to
more intimately interact with your
virtual environment it makes gameplay a
physical activity and induces a sense of
virtual presence in a way that
traditional game pads can't touch isn't
perfect but unless you're against a
little physical exertion it's a must buy
for every rift of the need it's a
necessary part of the package as far as
I'm concerned it feels like the missing
piece of the puzzle for more information
on the oculus rift head on over to
GameSpot comm and subscribe to our
YouTube channel
is dangerous duck underneath it
you